welcome everyone to our afternoon
session here this is kind of the more of
the workshop part of it I think it's a
good idea you're going to get some
really valuable insights into how
Washington works and how news reporters
cover Washington I'm going to let Jamie
go first what we'll do is we'll talk a
little bit about how we do our jobs as
reporters how how Washington works which
you know for most people it takes a long
time just to understand the mechanics of
Washington and then that's really the
starting point for good news coverage so
let me turn it over to Jamie and then
we'll go through this I think we have
about an hour and a half and we'll make
certain we'll leave plenty of time for
questions too okay okay well as you may
recall from the morning session I spent
most of my time covering the US military
from the safety of the Pentagon although
I did during the time that I was first
CNN military affairs correspondent and
then CNN senior Pentagon correspondent I
did in fact travel to all the war zones
usually after the bullets were had
stopped flying or the bombs and stopped
falling but sometimes there was a little
excitement while we were there as well
mostly though I checked when I traveled
at traveled with senior officials either
senior military officials or the defense
secretary on official trips occasionally
I would go by myself to war zones but
most of my reporting excuse me was done
in the Pentagon and the role of the
Pentagon reporter is to take all the
information that we get not just from
your own sources in the inside and
outside the Pentagon but also from the
other reporters in your organization who
are actually located where things are
going on
and through using your experience using
your trusted sources who have been
reliable in the past try to put together
a bigger picture of what's going on what
it means you know whether you're winning
the war losing the war whether the
strategy is working whether what the
government is saying actually reflects
what's going on on the ground and one of
the things that you discover excuse me
and this is true whether you're a
reporter or whether you're a senior
government official or a military
officer is that what you here at the
Pentagon rarely matches up with what's
actually going on in the field when
there are operations going on and this
is a challenge again I would sometimes
travel with senior military officials
and that was a challenge for them too
because when you go to a war zone if you
go to Afghanistan for instance today
you'll be treated to a used to be flip
charts but now it's PowerPoint briefings
on how how much progress is being made
how much things are better than the last
time but over time if you do this year
after year you discover that actually
things are not getting any better
they're not any different and when you
compete and actually talk to the people
who are actually conducting the
operations you awfully get a much
different perspective than what you get
from the Pentagon briefing the part the
couple of things about how you get
information from the Pentagon when I
first arrived at the Pentagon in 1992 I
was named the Pentagon correspondent in
November of 1992 President Bush was
leaving defense secretary Cheney was
leaving the new Clinton administration
was coming in and I thought I'd have a
little time to sort of figure out how
the place worked and of course within a
couple of weeks the US was intervening
in Somalia and that was sort of my you
know what one of standard rules of
journalism is as soon as you get
assigned some place where you think
you'll have some time to figure it out
something big happens right away and
I'll just one of the interesting
dynamics about the Pentagon is we you
know we talked a little bit earlier
today about why why sources leak why
information comes out that supposedly
it's not supposed to be released and a
lot of times it's simply to develop a
relationship with the report
order a lot of people know that they're
going to need the news media they're
going to need you at some point so they
want to do little favors for you now
that they're easy to do so that you'll a
trust them and BB more favorably
disposed to them and I was a beneficiary
of this policy when I first arrived at
the Pentagon because I I get to the
Pentagon the u.s. is landing in Somalia
the Marines are landing the marine recon
continents and forces are landing in
Somalia and I'm brand new there I've
only been there two weeks I'd pretty
much have a handle on the policy but I
don't know a lot of what's going on and
I'm live at the Pentagon and somebody
from the Navy decides to assign a young
naval officer to come down to the
Pentagon briefing room and help me out
because I'm clearly kind of lost I'm
watching the live feed on CNN from
Somalia and i'm watching this hovercraft
come ashore with with marines on it and
i've got right next to me off camera is
a young lieutenant commander who's been
dispatched by Navy public affairs to you
know build some rapport with the new
Pentagon correspondent and I'm saying to
Joe this this hovercraft that's coming
ashore what is what is that he said well
that's that's an elk ack and then said
well L kak what is lk staff where he
said that's a landing craft air cushion
and I said it was so what would be on
there and he said well you know what
have light armored vehicles and you know
that sort of thing and then not more
than about a minute later Bernie Shaw
who's the anchor at CNN comes to me and
says now let's go to our man at the
Pentagon Jamie McIntyre is there Jamie
what are we seeing here and I said well
Bernie this hovercraft that's coming
ashore is what's known as an L kak that
stands for landing craft air cushion and
it would have light armored vehicles and
that sort of thing on it and they did
this all night is young commander Joe
gratis you're stood just off camera and
explain to me what everything was as I
was seeing it like this the ship
offshore what says it's the USS Mount
Whitney I said what is a command and
control ship it has all kinds of Spain I
would come to me and I'd say and that
ship Bernie I believe is the USS Mount
Whitney if i'm not mistaken
but so I get home that night I'm feeling
pretty good you know I'm the coverage is
going pretty good i get home that night
and i said to my uh my wife I said so
did you did you see me on CNN's you see
how did Helen she says wow yeah I did
see season how did you know all that
stuff I said honey it's my job to know
that stuff but the point is there are a
lot of people to Pentagon who will help
you out and especially on sort of
routine routine things but the one of
the most valuable lessons I learned
early on and then I'll I'll turn this
over to Bill we want to leave plenty of
time for question but you know you think
that getting information is hard from
the Pentagon and it is getting you know
ferreting out secret information isn't
easy and after a while you sort of learn
how the game works and while the
perception is and sometimes it's does
happen the perception is that you get
some sort of big dump all at once and it
gives you like WikiLeaks you know they
just give you all the secret stuff and
then you just report it but often it's
this long sort of detective process
where you get a tiny piece of
information here and then a tiny piece
of information there and then you use
that piece of information to play off to
pretend that you know more than you do
and confront somebody who then thinks
you already have most of the story and
then they feel compelled to help you get
the rest of it to put in the right
context and then you use that then you
circle back to the original person who
didn't really tell you much at all but
gave you enough to start and then by
that time they think you've already been
given this story and you piece it
together and what would happen is if you
were to go back and question all 12
people you may have talked to you in the
course of a day or two each one of them
could honestly say I didn't give him the
story I mean all I told him was he was
you know he was way off track which by
the way can be very helpful and you know
they could honestly say I didn't leak
the story to them but in fact they were
all the source of the story but the most
valuable thing you can get is not
information it's not the it's the
question to ask the hardest thing to
discover at the Pentagon is it's just
like once you know that you should be
asking about something that something is
going on then you can sort of drill down
on it and find out but the hardest thing
is knowing what questions to ask knowing
you should be pursuing and there's a
number of ways that you can get it that
mean one of the things is you know
there's so much rivalry within the
government you know the between the
State Department and the Pentagon and
between the you know the Air Force and
the army and then you know the civilians
and you know one department after you
can play them off each other and one
common way to get reporters from looking
into something you don't want to look at
too deeply is to throw them a bone and
send them in a different direction of
you know it's like you go to the Navy to
look at some overpriced you know warship
and they say you know you should look at
that Air Force tanker deal i hear
there's something really going on with
that and it you know they send you off
that way and i'll just say one quick
story about this and then we'll take
your questions wherever you want to take
this so again early in my career at the
Pentagon CNN calls me up and this is at
the beginning of the Clinton
administration they there was a move to
lift the ban on the change the Pentagon
policy about gays in the military and
back then it was a it's actually part of
the Uniform Code of Military Justice
that gays couldn't serve in the military
there was a line in there that said
homosexuality is incompatible with
military service and the Clinton
administration was going to change that
it was a big controversy in CNN wanted
me to do a piece on that so ice course
as I explained the Pentagon says big
open building you can wander on so I set
wandering around the building trying to
find out what's going on with the gate
in the military policy and I run into
the Pentagon official I say look I need
to know what's going on with this policy
where's this heading and he says you
don't you don't ask about that you don't
want to know that I said yeah no that's
what I want to know see and then they
called me that's what the story they
want me to do today he said now you
don't want to you don't wanna do that
they said no it's like I'm thinking
where's this guy get off telling me what
story I'm gonna do I'm the reporter here
I get to decide what story I'm doing and
I'm pushing him and he finally says look
you don't get it you don't get it it's
not it's not gaze it's not gaze he says
I said what what do you mean he says
Somalia so what about so I already died
this i did a sore about Somalia
yesterday someone he says Somalia
Somalia and then he walks off and you
know I'm not the sharpest tool in the
shed but I'm beginning to think hmm
maybe I should ask about
Somalia I'm just thinkin maybe that's
where I should go and of course it
turned out the u.s. that night was going
to conduct a raid against Mohamed Farrah
Aidid who was the leader of the Somali
faction that we thought was the key to
success in Somalia and of course by
going around by knowing a little bit
about so now I'm using this technique
I'm going around saying hey I hear this
you know Somalia to something up within
like where'd you hear that you know it's
like and you can tell you one thing she
can help the pentagon's you go the the
advantage of like not doing things over
the phone but actually going to see
people is they react differently when
you when you see them in person so like
maybe an office you go into every day
everybody's pretty casual suddenly like
or somebody you can talk to you every
day something is not available they just
can't see you or you come in and people
start tearing papers over in their
office you know when you walk in you
know something is up a long story short
but as the course of the day by using
one little piece of information and then
pretending I knew more and then going to
somebody else and pretending to I
figured out about four in the afternoon
that this big raid was going off going
to go that night and of course it wasn't
something we could report ahead of time
because this would compromise the
mission but what I did do was I called
CNN and I said you know we this is back
before the internet and all the
communications we have today so CNN
devising a cover story that it was going
to do a special on Somalia bought up all
available satellite time at a mogadishu
that night and then I get this call back
from the presidency and Isis Jamie we've
just spent 75 thousand dollars buying
all the satellite time so I hope their
sources are right because otherwise is
costing us a lot of money and so now I'm
really nervous
because I'm thinking so of course the
raid went off as expected we were
expecting it we had the exclusive
because nobody else could get satellite
time out of there we're all over time a
big hero and because I get to keep my
job for another 16 years but the point
of that is that it's if you get the
questions the answers will come usually
okay you know what I want to do is give
you a little bit of an overview about
covering Washington and share with you
my experience and doing this for 26
years it's been absolutely an incredible
career for me I mean like I say if I
walked away from the news business I'd
have I'd have no regrets I've been all
over the world I've covered some amazing
stories of you know I've traveled to
former Soviet missile bases in the
middle of Siberia and places like that
and it's just been you know one thing
that you don't often get from reporters
is that it's a lot of fun I mean I
really had a lot of fun fact Jamie and I
we we had some fun on a number of trips
to Asia we travel with the Secretary of
Defense and you get to go in motorcades
and you fly on a plane that doesn't stop
for 24 hours as refuels in the air
several times but first a little bit
about the news business obviously you
know you have to answer the question
what is news and in Washington you know
the main industry here is government and
government and politics are the main
thing if you go to New York it's finance
Los Angeles it's entertainment but here
it's it's government so the focus on
news here is mainly about government and
government is made up of the three
branches but then there's all the trade
associations and lobbyists and all of
these a very good movie to understand
the lobby side a thing is a movie that
came out fairly recently called casino
jack about Jack Abramoff which kind of
gives you a flavor about the the free
willing lobbyists seen that ended up
putting him in prison the state of the
news business today
as I'm sure you're aware you know that's
obviously the big question will there be
newspapers in the next 10-15 years you
know there will be newspapers I'm
confident of that what format they'll be
in I'm not so confident of the problem
today is that print readership is
declining and digital readership is
increasing but the money that was used
to fund newspapers from advertisements
is not migrating at the same rate to the
Digital side I think the the figures for
2009 more that 45 billion dollars was
spent in print ads but only about 5
billion was spent on digital ads so
there's a that's a big problem nobody's
really figured out how to monetize this
new digital world and the culture right
now is that everybody wants it free
they're starting to look at pay walls
and how to how to do those things but so
that's that's the real dilemma for
newspapers the other downside of that is
that most of the comp the the content
that appears on the internet comes from
established news organizations the ones
that were built with brick and mortar
and established so people are there's
there's certainly uncertainty about
about the future a little bit about the
newsgathering process it's it's fast
paced especially for daily newspaper and
it's driven by a strong sense of
competition there are lots of reporters
out there hundreds perhaps maybe
thousands of reporters kind of covering
the the same thing you do also there are
trade associations and trade journals
specialized publications that focus on
government regulation or energy or very
specific things but for a general
interest news paper there's a lot of
competition there's generally two types
of reporting that we do one we call
breaking news which is
where the Secretary of Defense or
someone will hold a press conference or
will appear before Congress and you have
to find the story there I can remember
starting out as a young reporter in in
the 1980s and it was very difficult for
me to find out what was going on what
was the news out of a story and it took
a long time to get that experience and
after a while after you cover something
for a long time it almost becomes second
nature that you know that something has
been said maybe several months ago and
then something is said even slightly
different and it represents something
that has gone on behind the scenes
they've had you know dozens of
high-level government meetings and they
made a decision and they've changed the
policy so it's a news story and you have
to figure out how they change the policy
why they changed it what's the
significance of it and then you have to
put all of that into a story through
technical writing and of course
reporters don't operate alone they have
to have good editors and editors provide
the experience they provide the reality
check and they can also be a pain in the
ass I mean anybody that's ever had to
deal with that is I was been very
fortunate to have good editors
especially in covering national security
affairs for example during the Clinton
administration one of the really big
areas where we as of newspaper were able
to carve out a niche was on the issue of
missile defense and it was it was pretty
easy to understand why what was going on
then was back in 91 and during the first
Gulf War the largest single number of
casualties occurred when a scud missile
was fired from Iraq into Saudi Arabia
and it landed on a barracks in Dhahran
killed a number of people and so the
military understood that they needed
some defenses against these missiles
which are relatively unguided but yet
they can do tremendous damage
and at the same time the Clinton
administration very much like the
current administration had adopted what
I call a pro arms control approach to
defense it wasn't the Reagan view of
peace through strength it was peace
through negotiations the only problem
with that is that you know in in
international affairs the u.s. is
usually the only one that negotiates
honestly and not in its own interest and
so what you end up with is you have
agreements that restrict the US while
other nations violate them well here you
had a situation where the Clinton
administration was very enamored with a
1972 arms control treaty called the
anti-ballistic missile treaty and it
basically was said that we won't build
defenses against nuclear missiles so
their way will be vulnerable and things
will be stable and they don't like
missile defense because they think that
it creates instability when in fact if
you can defend against missiles you
don't have to worry about the offensive
missiles anyway it was an offensive
defensive thing the Clinton people
wanted to extend this long-range missile
defense ban two short-range missiles and
the military was horrified their guys
had died in a short-range missile attack
they didn't want to give up the ability
to do very effective short-range missile
defenses well this is a classic case
where you're going to get good news
stories it's not an easy area to cover
it was very technical it had to do is
interceptor speeds and velocities the
editors recognize that hey this is an
area we can excel in this is an area
where we can carve out unique exclusive
coverage and we did and because there
was this fight between the military that
wanted short-range missile defenses and
the political appointees who wanted to
limit missile defenses it became a great
story for us so that that's kind of a
good example of how you you find good
areas that's your what we call a
breaking news area or an enterprise area
and that's a that's a second category
enterprises where we also call
investigate
reporting I'm reluctant to use a term
investigative reporting because many
times it's an excuse for reporters to
write one story every six months very
few news organizations have that luxury
now we at the times we have an
investigative team and you know they
work away and they get inside stories
and they develop pretty good stories but
you want to get stories that no one else
has because it will drive people to read
your newspaper or to go to your website
that's really the key and again it gets
back to this this competition news
sources of course this is really the key
to being a good reporter developing and
keeping good sources and as I said in my
career I've been very fortunate to be
able to get excellent sources i mean
it's if i were to really talk about all
of it you know it would probably in this
environment lead to all kinds of
investigations but the most important
thing is to protect your sources many
times people who provided me information
i had to protect them because it wasn't
clear to them that what would happen if
i reported something and whether or not
they could be detected it wasn't too
long into my career that i found out
that the CIA in particular had a whole
shop of people who did nothing but read
the newspaper and follow news reports
and try to figure out where the
information came from in other words
they were they were hunting for leaks
but in just a couple of examples i mean
i had sources that were both people and
also documents people would provide
documents on what was going on and i can
remember a case where i got a document
that was highly classified and in it it
disclosed that there was going to be a
coup in a south american country and i
thought to myself what am i going to do
with this say say I mean I could have
reported it straight a classified
document said there was going to be a
coup in some South American country and
but then
I thought well what if there's not a
coup so and what if I start you know
doing the legwork on this to find out
hey you know do you know about this as
anybody know man anyway so I it was
toward the end of the week and I decided
that I would make a few phone calls and
see what you know what the response was
because in this business there's one
thing that you you can't do enough of
and that's ask questions you have if you
ask even there are really no dumb
questions yeah but as long as you ask
questions you will be absolutely amazed
to see what answers you get in this case
I asked a few questions from some
officials in government and I said I'll
wait wait on the weekend and somehow
over the weekend there was a report that
came out a wire report that said they
had arrested a group of officers in
South American country who were plotting
a coup so I you know that it wasn't
something that I really needed to report
but I think that it to me it was an
amazing that i was getting access to
this information and of course at the
time the government really did have a
very hands-off approach to the press it
really wasn't until the second Bush
administration that they're developed
within government kind of a group of
people who felt that they were going to
go after the press that they were going
to that the press was causing more
damage than you know even the worst spy
cases that they've had now my view is if
you look at the spy cases that we've had
there's never been any disclosure in the
press that's come close to what has
happened through these betrayals of
these spies Hansen and aims at the top
of the list but there's their scores up
and so so they're developed a group that
went after reporters and that's when
they really started going after sources
and again like I said this is a business
where you want to develop sources how do
you develop sources it was mentioned
this morning one of the really good
source pools is former of
officials and one of the within that
group people who have just left
government are also very good sources
people that are about to leave
government are about to retire also can
be various good sources well how do you
meet these people well you know I live
in Maryland I've lived in maryland since
the 70s and it seems like in lived in
bowie for a long time and and seemed
like for every other house somebody
there worked for the National Security
Agency which is the most secretive
agency in government I mean for a long
time people who work for NSA they just
wouldn't say anything where they worked
then after a while it changed the
loosened up a little bit and they said
yeah I work for the u.s. government and
I said oh what part of the US government
well I can't tell you and then then it
became a little looser and they said I
work for the Defense Department I said
whoa you work at the Pentagon no I can't
tell you where I work and then finally
they said they work for NSA so then then
once you they say NSA you know they're
not going to say anything else but NSA
is one of the most secretive government
agencies and it's also without doubt the
most effective intelligence service in
the world in terms of gathering
information i would say probably eighty
to ninety percent of all the
intelligence gathered by the US
government comes from the NSA which does
electronic eavesdropping and
code-breaking and they do that through a
number of means they have ground
stations they have satellites that can
intercept signals they have aircraft and
they use it's just a huge gigantic
system and to be able to gather that
information that's difficult but then be
able to sift it and find useful
intelligence that's really amazing and
of course they don't like to tell their
story their one of the more secret
agencies the CIA on the other hand has
really changed in recent years it's
really become much more of a human
intelligence agency at least they've
tried to do that the problem there is
that our human intelligence was
decimated in the 70s when they made
conscious decision look human spying is
too hard it gets you in trouble it's
illegal in most places so let's just do
electronic spine well you know what you
can't spy electronically on a terrorist
group that doesn't use communications I
mean even if bin Laden had a satellite
phone yeah but anyway so I'm getting a
little bit off the topic there but
anyway so I've covered these things and
I've dealt with incredible amounts of
information sometimes to the point where
I you know I'd have to wait a certain
point and I'd have to write about it and
officials would you know Oh bill gertz
is calling what's he going to ask us
about and it was it was a really an
amazing experience for me I think one of
the kind of a metaphor for my career is
I got a haircut many years ago and I was
talking to the the barber and Barbara I
told him I was a reporter he says Oh
have you met the president and I said no
but I read his mail and what I meant by
that was that somebody had actually
leaked me a copy of a letter from
Russian president Boris Yeltsin to Bill
Clinton and it talked about
anti-satellite weapons I mean it was a
great story it revealed that the
Russians had an anti-satellite missile
and that they wanted the u.s. to
negotiate not to develop satellite
weapons but it was you know it was dear
bill and then I've gotten a lot of those
kinds of stories in my career's if i
were to think back at some of the bigger
stories one was a a confidential
memorandum of conversation between bill
clinton and boris yeltsin it was at the
summit meeting in Sharm el-sheikh Egypt
where you had it was right before
Clinton was running for reelection maybe
I think late 90s and in it you have
Clinton telling Yeltsin look Boris you
and I are both running for president
let's not do anything to upset relations
between our countries and oh by the way
Russia is blocking imports of us chicken
and a lot of that chicken is made in
Arkansas
with my good friends down there so is
there any chance you can get your
government to lift the ban on chicken
anyway it was just a great story I mean
it wasn't and the the White House just
went crazy the Russians issued a you
know when we wrote the story about it
they said they were issued a formal
diplomatic protest that that the
government had leaked this confidential
exchange between the two presidents so I
can say that's that's kind of a let me
see I just want to check my notes and
we'll see if there's I'll sum up here
okay okay yeah if I wanted to go through
a few of the stories that kind of shaped
my career i mean when i first started
and I wish Brian Kelly was here because
I i started in 1985 and that became
known as the year of the spy we had like
I don't know five or six major spy cases
so it was almost like a spy mania had
gripped the government they were
prosecuting spies right and left and
first was John Walker who provided codes
navy codes that actually would have
allowed the Soviet Union to win if we if
we had a hot war and then there was a
National Security Agency spy named
Ronald Pelton and I almost got in
trouble over that because he had
compromised a underwater listening
program where the Navy had secretly gone
and was able to tap underwater cables in
the Russian Far East and that was
compromised by the spy it was known as
Ivy bells and the Russians knew about it
and the NSA knew about it but nobody in
the public knew about it and the
government was trying to prosecute this
spy but at the same time not let that
information come out so it was myself a
Washington Post reporter and an NBC
reporter who were threatened with
prosecution if we were disclosed that I
I don't even remember all the details
but eventually it came out
you know one one or all three of our
news organizations reported on that then
there was the r and Contra affair there
was the Pan Am flight 103 bombing in 88
the first Gulf War World Trade Center
one I mentioned missile defense I
mentioned China maybe China's was one
area that I've been focusing on and and
I got interested in that why i went to
the Pentagon for a background briefing I
was doing something on the Chinese
military and at that time the Defense
Intelligence Agency would actually
provide you with a briefing that you
would attribute to defense official or
something and I had this briefing and
during the briefing somebody came in and
said the general would like to see you
and I said okay and the general was the
the the director of the agency and he
SAT me down he said well bill I want to
tell you something I want to tell you
that china is not a threat and I said
well okay why do you think that and he
went on explaining his whole views on
that because of their statements and all
these things and it was pretty amazing
to me but it got me thinking about this
because I kept hearing this theme
everywhere I went in government China is
not a threat China is not a threat i
said well you know why do we say that
they're not a threat I mean there are
communist dictatorship they have nuclear
weapons and missiles that can hit us but
why are they so aggressively insisting
it's not a threat and that ended up
becoming a book that I did called the
China threat interestingly enough which
kind of highlighted all of these issues
and it came out right around the time of
a big Chinese nuclear spy scandal which
is another good story that we had the
the New York Times won a Pulitzer Prize
for it reporting on a los alamos
scientist and then they repudiated their
own reporting by saying that it was it
was bad and then you know the guy got
off because he was chinese-american
anyway that was a whole story that FB i
botched the investigation let me just
conclude with a few comments about the
technical aspects of writing
thatthat's you know once you get all of
your facts together and you're ready to
put the story together a lot of times
you don't have a lot of time to do that
I mean you can rely on the editors to to
backstop you and help you fill in the
gas but you really have to figure out
what the information is what's the most
important part of that information and a
lot of times a good method to do for
that is to think in terms of headlines
what's the headline of the story you
know and if you if you can think if you
can put it in a few words and and this
is very relevant to today's Twitter and
and that's one of the the new media that
I've learned to rely on is Twitter I
don't I don't follow people who tell me
they're going for a hamburger or yoga
class but but I have a lot of really
good news sources and they're all over
the world it can be the Israeli Defense
Forces spokesman and they they'll tweet
when they arrest Palestinians it could
be the sum of the blog's that break
stories about what's going on inside
Pakistan but you think in terms of a
headline in Twitter terms it's 140
characters minus the shortened URL and
then of course the lead of the story you
need to have a compelling lead and you
you want to be able to write very
clearly and concisely and tell the
reader right up front what you're going
to tell them in the rest of the story
and you know it may sound like something
that's easy but it's it's definitely not
easy to do and but but always try to
write very clear and concise leads and
then of course there's the the basic
rules of writing use active verbs /
passive prefer shorter to longer simple
to complex and but most importantly
understand your topic it's often been
compared that that newspaper reporters
when they write a story they become
instant experts the way one person
described it is it's like for every
story you have a bathtub and you fill it
up with information that you need for
that story and then you put all the
pieces you learn about it you put all
the pieces together and when you're done
you pull the plug and the information
goes down the drain
and then you fill them up for the next
story so it's kind of like that process
to get all of your information keep
asking questions that I think it was
Judith Miller who described it in
intelligence terms you know in the
intelligence world they have entz for
intelligence they have human for human
intelligence they have SIGINT for
signals intelligence and they have a
whole bunch of others but in the in the
news business they call it ask int in
other words you ask the questions and
that will produce the intelligence that
you need for your stories and as I said
earlier that's a really an amazing
amazing thing we if you ask enough
people it's almost like being a
door-to-door salesman if you've ever had
to sell things door-to-door you know
that if you keep knocking on doors
eventually you're going to sell
something I mean that's that's pretty
much the way it works in Washington if
you ask long enough pretty much you you
know obviously there are some places
that your doors that won't be open but
you'll get a lot of information just
from asking it's like I say it's a very
unruly and competitive business but one
of the things that makes us an advantage
here is that we have absolutely the most
open society in the world as as Jamie
mentioned in his remarks it's really
amazing that you can walk through the
Pentagon I mean I can remember doing
that to walking past the the Secretary
of Defense's office and he'd be in there
working and have his personnel
everywhere but because we're open people
like to come to reporters oftentimes
reporters are the the last line of their
defense they've gone to their
administrator they may have gone to
Congress they may even have gone to the
courts and they didn't get any relief
for whatever problem they see so then
they'll go to reporters oftentimes it's
not always a story sometimes it is and
so reporters often get volunteers as I
think Brian mentioned but try to develop
the sources you go to conferences you
talk to former officials ask those
questions and if somebody doesn't know
you ask the next question is well can
you tell me someone that
is no and then they can give you a
referral so a lot of think tanks in town
often provide good kind of source things
but it's a source intensive business
it's it's a very social business it
requires good people skills there's a
lot of mutual back-scratching you know
and that by that I mean how do you know
I've developed sources by going to the
State Department and doing an
on-the-record interview with someone
from the oceanic bureau talking about
the environment and so on and that has
ended up producing a very good sources
people who can be sources of information
for other stories they they call that in
the news business a beat sweetener story
something that will help enhance your
ability to to do things and the more you
write on a certain subject you also will
attract additional information from
other people who might contact you and
of course now with the digital
technology a lot of people will contact
you and say hey you're exactly right and
by the way did you know about this a lot
of times some stories don't work out and
you know oftentimes reporters just get
totally blown away that their story
didn't work out or something didn't
happen don't worry about it the way the
way the news business is there's always
another story if one story doesn't work
out you can be assured with one hundred
percent confident that there'll be other
stories down the road okay I think at
that point I'll stop and we'll open up
doing what I just want to say before we
take questions I'll make this really
quick but just a couple of points I know
a lot of what we've been talking about
seems like it's from the Jurassic area
of journalism you know we're telling you
war stories from the 70s 80s and maybe
into the 90s so I just wanted to just
talk a little bit about how things have
changed it's sort of bring it back to
today and then we'll open it up to your
questions when I started as a
correspondent at CNN of course CNN made
its real reputation with the 1991
persian gulf war and its coverage of
that and it was pretty amazing back then
because we could we could actually get
live pictures from the battlefield using
these
portable earth stations that we develop
called flyaways which was basically a
big satellite dish and in just 21 cases
of equipment you can only five people to
operate it we could actually go live
from pretty much anywhere where we could
hit a satellite flash forward to 2008
when I left CNN my last report I did
from Iraq I did I was traveling by
myself I did it with my little macbook
pro with the web camera that's in the
macbook and a little portable device
called a began or broadband the global
area network it's basically a satellite
access to the internet through that I
connected my computer to the internet
just like you would do something over
your webcam on your macbook I was able
to broadcast a live report from Baghdad
back to CNN and it looked pretty good i
actually have a clip of this on my blog
if anybody's interested in seeing how it
how it looked and how i put it together
but you know when I first started CNN I
was a television correspondent a network
television correspondent and I had
producers and when I went out I would
not with a camera crew and a sound
technician and you know when I was back
in the bureau I had makeup artists and
producers helping me by the time I left
CNN I was pretty much doing everything
myself you know writing for the web
filing for radio taking pictures
shooting and editing video as I said
doing my own live report directly from
my be from my computer and you know the
the as I mentioned earlier this morning
the the rise of the internet and all the
competition changed the product that CNN
was creating because they no longer had
to provide a lot of routine information
they just want to concentrate on certain
too hot stories but it also changed the
way we covered things so for instance
like catherine herridge who mentioned
how important it was to get down to
guantanamo and witnessed the cases I too
wanted to go to Guantanamo to cover the
one of the first military commissions of
the trial of Salim Hamdan who is the man
accused of being Osama bin Laden's
driver and bodyguard
I felt it was a really important case I
wanted to be there but CNN was not
interested in spending the money to send
you know crew and producers and
satellites and all that so armed with
this new technology of being able to
essentially do things myself I made the
pitch that I should just go by myself
doesn't cost me CNN anything because I
was under salary and didn't get over
time so they paid me the same whether
I'm sitting at the Pentagon or whether
I'm sitting in a courtroom in Guantanamo
but it did make it more difficult to
cover because i had to do not just the
normally i would just go down there i
would sit in the courtroom watch
everything you know case anybody through
a paper plane or something that was
going to be significant and then I'd
come out and report it well because I'm
now doing all the technical stuff as
well I'm setting up the camera getting a
little you know acquiring the satellite
laying all the cables dealing with all
the logistics I'm sort of short changing
the times i'm spending in the courtroom
plus another dynamic has happened in
that CNN is not as interested in the
story as I am I think it's a pretty
interesting fascinating story but it's a
complex legal issue about to what extent
the right these terrorist suspects have
rights and how it's being handled in the
court it's kind of a complex issue so
one day and this is just illustrative of
how the business change one day I hear
that they're going to allow the pool
photographers to go take a picture of
the cells where they keep the high-value
al-qaeda suspects it's an empty cell but
it's it's representative of the kind of
accommodations they've had because
they're trying to counter the impression
that somehow the conditions their
inhumane so I say hey I want to go along
they say so look this is only for
photographers it's not really for
reporters it's just so they can get some
pictures I said hey I'm a photographer
too I'm not just a reporter I'm
everything they said okay yeah well you
can go but you have to wait till the
real photographers go through and then
then we'll give you a minute you can go
in so I go in to this little cell I've
got maybe I'd literally have like two
minutes and I've got my little video
camera and I hold the camera up I'm
holding it up and I'm looking and I just
talking to the camera I saying like this
is a cell where they hold a high-value
suspects and I'm kind of
turning around this and you can see
behind me it's got a window but you
can't see out of it and here's what they
get I try to turn the camera and I edit
this into a little piece and I send it
to CNN now I'm having a hard time
getting on the air with the store with
the legal complex legal story about the
military commissions and the trial of
hominin but this little piece of video
which basically doesn't really break any
journalistic ground this is really
highly promotable you know this is so
it's like now you're hanging like to
tonight a CNN exclusive inside al Qaeda
cell where the worst of the worst are
being held we takin a CNN exclusive we
take you inside this piece rat like 16
times which is sort of illustrative of
the kind of the trend of how things are
going this was a very you know there's
nothing wrong with the piece it was kind
of interesting I wouldn't have done it
if I didn't think it was interesting but
it was it was a it really struck me how
that kind of a story which was much more
fluffy much more sort of lends itself to
being hyped and sensationalized was much
more appealing to the producers who were
putting their shows together on CNN than
the more complex story that I was having
trouble I did get to do the other story
as well it just wasn't as easy to get
that one on the air so I want to leave
time for questions so I'll stop we ask
that you wait for the microphone before
you ask a question because we are
recording this so we could just raise
your hand and we'll bring a microphone
hi my question is have you ever covered
a story that was so sensitive in nature
that you received threats of some kind
that you were afraid for your life or
perhaps been in an area where you were
covering a story and you thought that
your life might be in danger
I have personally eyes up I think the
most threats that I've received from CIA
agent they once threatened fire crews on
my desk
some stomach critical after operation
been criticized by Russian government
they go into the CIA within the usual
Chinese government wanted a piece where
they listed the top 10 and how China
experts in the world
Wow
you know I've never really felt
throughout the journal are we on there
we go yeah I've never really felt
threatened by anything I've been in some
dicey situations overseas but but
nothing you know nothing really
life-threatening no you probably yeah
well um I've never you know I've never
been threatened because of anything I've
reported i have like bill been in
situations that were you know dangerous
particularly in retrospect you know not
the least of which was on the Pentagon
in September 11 where apparently
somebody tried to you know attack the
building with a airplane but you know
and part of that is because of the
relationship that I had with the people
I covered in that you know I don't think
anybody thought I was out to get any one
item it worked really hard to establish
a reputation of somebody who was really
trying to get the story right and if
somebody I think thought I didn't quite
capture it right there wasn't a lot of
animosity there but I you know I was
because I was in the military i covered
the militarized in lots of situations
where things happened i was on a
helicopter that accidentally landed too
close to the North Korean border I was
in a helicopter that went down because a
hot draw hydraulic line burst is in
Somalia when a bunch of mortar rounds
went right over her head and I was on
the plane that that crashed and killed
Ron Brown the Commerce Secretary the day
before his plane crashed he flew in the
same place we flew in the day before but
when his plane landed it crashed inside
of a mountain so I've had some sort of
near death experiences but nothing that
was directed at me personally
um Chairman wolseley talked about how if
you're interested in getting a
government job sometimes it helps to
just get your foot in the door and
there's some opportunity for sideways
mobility for us here who are interns
trying into the field of journalism in
particular I've been to know how each of
you kind of got your start and where you
are today and covering the topics you're
covering okay in my case I I think my
first journalism job was with a sister
paper to the Washington Times called the
New York City Tribune and i think it was
back in like nineteen seventy nine where
I covered the what was known as the FBI
trial and it was a water the end of the
Watergate era trial of Mark felt and
edward s miller and they were both
convicted of illegal break-ins turned
out later that mark felt happened to be
deep throat the famous watergate source
nobody knew it at the time but you know
I kind of you know I think Watergate was
a pivotal event for a lot of people in
my generation and that's kind of
inspired me to be a reporter to be able
to break big stories i joined the times
in 85 i came on board when they named a
new editor arnaud de Bourgh krav who i
knew a little bit and he basically gave
me my start and kind of protected me and
and that was kind of my career Ian I
think that was that's how I started it's
definitely not an easy job environment
out there but I think that there will be
journalism jobs it's just going to be
you know striving to be really excellent
and and with the new media and
proliferation of new media you can set
yourself apart by learning and showing
your reporting skills online and then
that will capture somebody's attention
yeah there's really two parts to this
question one is how did I get my
excellent job and one is how do you get
your excellent job now I'm going to make
this as short as possible I went to
journalism school got journalism degree
you don't need a journalism degree to be
a journalist it does what you do need is
some sort of experience that you can
keep building on and journalism school
does give you some of that some
practical skills that you can use to try
to get that first job once you get a job
you learn most of the stuff you need on
the job there is a value of journalism
school though and things like studying
law of mass communications ethics things
that maybe you don't have time to
discuss in the newsroom you know I in
broadcasting and I went most my career
has been in broadcasting there's really
two routes that you can take you either
start small in a big market or a big
organization like CNN you start as a you
know some lowly but they call them
vijay's that they call them at CNN or
you go to a small market and you start
big there and you keep moving to bigger
and bigger markets both have its
disadvantages because the biggest
obstacle you have and you know it's true
you have to get it's just like anything
else you have to get your foot in the
door internships are a good way to do
that the challenge you always have is
always convincing somebody you can do
something other than what you're doing
right now people tend to see why quit if
you take a job in the tape library at
CNN when I said well you know he's just
a tape library and you know he's like
you got to constantly convince people
that you can do something other than
what you're doing so you know when i
started i started in radio i was off the
air i had to convince them I could be on
the air I everyone and it in one
universal thing that will happen
everywhere is at some point someone will
tell you you just really don't have what
it takes and you should consider doing
something else almost everybody has had
that experience resume says you know you
really not cut out for this so when I
was off the air I had to get on the air
in radio when I was in radio I couldn't
convince anybody I could do television
when I got in the television I ended up
doing feature stories and they didn't
think I couldn't convince them I could
do hard news then I got to do cover the
Pentagon so I did hard news then then
then I had the convinced that then I was
I went back to radio that I've convinced
people i could do commercial radio or
public radio which is different and so
you've got constantly sort of facing
that thing but one of the things is you
just keep at it until everybody else
gives up now these days it's also it's
also different because in the old days
you know you'd put together a clip file
if you were a newspaper or you put
together a tape reel if you were trying
to get into upper
cast journalism and now it's all about
online you know you need you if you
haven't already you need a blog or a
website that showcases your work that as
you do things and even whether it's for
school or whether it's in turn or
whether something you did for free you
can showcase your talents I teach as an
adjunct professor at the University of
Maryland I teach multimedia journalism
now in which i teach creating videos
slideshows and that sort of thing for
the web because that's what all
reporters need to be able to do these
days and it's and it's a great way to
you know these states if you go apply
for a job what they want to see is they
want to be able to go to your website
and see what you've done and they want
to be able to see that you've you
understand new media that your twitter
feed is displayed on your site and all
all that's up and then you're just
competing with everybody else one quick
story when I first started in 85 at the
times more the guy who sat next to me
was an old old reporter I mean he must
have been in his late 70s smoked like a
chimney constantly cough I thought he
was going to die he got his job back in
the in the late 40s because he was a
reporter in Atlanta Georgia and there
was a hotel fire and he ran inside the
hotel fire and got the guest register
and went to Associated Press and they
hired him on the spot
yes I would love if you could both speak
to developing relationships with sources
and how you maintain enough independence
from them but yet developed trust and
then also when you have to burn sources
have you had to burn sources never
burned a source and there might be one
exception there I think may be very
early on there was some professor who
went on the record with the Washington
Post but would only say the same thing
to me on background and I basically
burned him I used his name but that was
it that was the only time I've always
observed a very strict rule about
protecting sources as I said protecting
your sources and having a reputation for
protecting your sources is crucial to
being able to develop more so I was
always very stringent about that you
know I've been friends with some of my
sources of you know I played sports with
some of them others have it's been very
you know professional arm's length it's
been you know they want something out if
it's news will report on it you know if
if it's not as much news but it's still
marginally newsy yeah I'll report it
okay maybe that will and then lead to a
bigger story I mean you have to you know
weigh it and you have to be careful you
know that those are that would be my
advice well I've never burned a source
but I wouldn't say that I wouldn't burn
a source I might because I don't think
these rules are in violet and they
generally work really well but if you
burn somebody you have to decide what
the consequences are and whether there's
a greater good now just give it a quick
example I know how many of you are
familiar with the michael hastings
profile of general stanley mcchrystal
that ended up getting the crystal fire
and there's a lot of discussion because
a lot of what he reported is typically
off the record and not for reporting and
that generated a discussion about
whether reporters are too cozy with
these sources that they're willing to
put too much stuff off the record to
protect their relationship with their
sources and so when I was discussing
this in a cadet
make sense they some-some one of my
friends argued well you know thought the
record then you can never report it
under any circumstances well I'm not
sure that's true because you could
decide that you were going to night said
let's let's take an example let's say
I'm traveling with a just a four-star
general and we having an off-the-record
discussion we've agreed it's off the
record and we're just going to have a
beer and chat about how things are going
and let's say he referred to President
Obama using the n-word I'm just making
this up but it's off the record well now
I might decide that this is so egregious
that this is such a disrespectful thing
and it violates the Uniform Code of
Military Justice and shows contempt for
our commander-in-chief I might decide
that I can't keep that off the record i
would probably go to the general and say
look what you said last night I I can't
honor I can't keep that off the record
and he might say well you know if you
report this you'll be violating and I'd
say well you know you do what you have
to do and I'll do what I have to do so
it's not it you note on a ton of federal
law it's not even a moral thing it's
just it's really an agreement between
two people which gets back to what is
the relationship how do you develop
sources your relationship with sources
is very much a marriage of convenience
you know it's not that they love you
because you're such a great person or
that you respect it's like you need each
other you're using them and they're
using you and what you just want is for
that debt mutual using to be based on
accuracy and honesty and it's a there's
a process that goes there's a sort of
courting that goes on between you and
the source they want to know that if
they release if they give you
information that you're going to handle
it responsibly you're going to provide
the context they're going to give them a
fair shake not necessarily that you're
going to do a story that's that's you
know favorable to them but just that
they're going to get a fair shake and
that you're smart enough to understand
it and you're going to put in the proper
context that's what they're looking for
generally and by the same token what
you're looking from them is that they're
giving you accurate information that
while they might be providing their
their what they would their view is
they're not giving you spin
and that what they told you turns out to
be true later and at every point when
they give you information at some point
you find out if it's actually true or
not sometimes it's the next day
sometimes it's a week sometimes it's a
year later so over time you calibrate
what you get from each person you decide
you know the term reliable sources means
that you've these people have been
reliable what they've told you in the
past has panned out the the spin has
been you know either straightforward and
honest or it's not there and by the same
token they land so over time you develop
a relationship with people that you feel
you can trust because they've been
reliable in the past and they feel they
can trust you and they may they may just
totally want to make sure they have some
friends in the media and that's and it's
it's difficult source management is the
hardest thing because people are
constantly leaving people are in a
position where they can you develop a
really great source to get to be a
four-star general and then they're gone
they're rather than maybe we had no
access to information same thing with
reporters they have a great relationship
with the reporter and with the exception
of a few people like Bill who are on the
beat forever you know they're you've got
a great relationship then they're gone
they're covering something else so it's
you constantly have to be working on
it's probably the most labor-intensive
part of your job is just managing your
sources and it also brings up the issue
of anonymous sources which we really
didn't discuss but definitely should you
know I think there was a there was a
case a number of years ago that the
Washington Post put in place a law that
a rule that said no more anonymous
sources everything has to be
attributable to someone on the record
well it didn't last very long at all I
mean it because it was just too hard to
compete but the government has decided
that for whatever reason they want to
give out information but they don't want
it it attributed directly today a
specific person or in some cases a
specific agency and it's created a lot
of problems the purists in the news
business say we should never use it we
should fight against the use of
anonymous sources my view is I have you
know my view is if the information is
accurate and can be attributed
in a way that is satisfying minimum
standards from this agency from this
person with access to it then I'm ok
with it and I've in a built my career on
it and up I've tried to err on the side
of caution if you know we we really need
two sources of information when we write
a sort when we write a story you know
but as is the case with many of the
rules and journalism you break most of
them you know I think journalistic rules
are is kind of an oxymoron you you
follow the rules but for example if the
one of the sources happens to be the
deputy secretary of state you're going
to bend the rules because that's that's
fairly credible now if the deputy
secretary of state gives you bad
information that will be your loss and
it will be it's something that you
really really have to be careful of
because in newspapers and news
organizations live and die on their
credibility and if you get them wrong I
mean the New York Times can can get a
few more wrong than the washington times
and and still survive and of course
they've had their problems too there's
been the Jayson Blair scandal and we've
had the Jack Kelly scandal where you
have reporters fabricating things and
then they try to tighten up on the the
anonymous source rules generally the the
the levels go if you're on the record
everything the person says can be
attributed if it's on background it can
be it can't be attributed by name and
then you have to really be clear on the
rules can you say that this is from a
State Department official can you say
it's from a Defense Department official
sometimes that's okay sometimes it they
don't want that I'm not sure the reason
Jamie probably has a better sense for
why they don't want certain information
attributed it's usually based on their
own internal politics and then there's
the category called off the record and
off the record is what I try to avoid
the most I remember many years ago the
CIA opened its counterterrorism center
and they had all these TV sets and
computers it was a big deal and we got
out there of group of reporters and they
told us it was off the record and I said
wait a minute I said I don't want it I'm
not out here to see your new TV sets I'm
here
write a story and so they had to have a
big meeting about whether they could
change the ground rules from off the
record to on background and they
eventually agreed because I was ready to
walk out and want to do I don't want to
do stuff that I can't use for my story
now what is off the record mean that
means that the information that person
gives you can't be reported does that
mean that you can't take that
information and go to someone else and
say hey what do you know about this and
if they tell you that does that mean
that you're violating well I don't know
the answer to that and I don't want to
know the answer so in other words
there's a certain ambiguity any time any
person government official imparts
information to you with caveats you know
try your best to abide by the rules but
you know remember that any time they
release information they released it to
you they could release it to someone
else yeah I just say one more thing
about off the record i wrote a piece
about off the record and what it means
for the American journalism review which
you could google if you wanted to see it
but essentially this is my definition of
off the record off the record means not
reporting in any form unless it's really
really good and I only say that hapless
easily because I as in the example I
gave earlier we could be off the record
if it turns out it's big in a big enough
deal the only way anything's at
principal nothing's off the record in a
group setting because somebody's going
to tell somebody going to tell so it's
going to get out the only way things
should be off the record if it's between
two people and they trust each other
particularly if one of them is dead then
you're pretty safe but it has to be two
people it's a matter of trust of that
between those two people beyond that
once you're in sort of a group situation
like McChrystal was traveling and stuff
off the record I mean yeah it's kind of
off the record but if something you know
if we're if we're not the record
situation and something bad happens it's
going to get it's going to get reported
so it's um yeah and so and if you're and
if you're in a conversation with
somebody and they say look in order to
explain that to you I have to go I'm
gonna have to go off the record that's
your signal to say
no let's just stay on the record a while
longer and then you get to distend you
can dislike you don't want to accept
anything off the record because now
you're going to be because even if you
do get it someplace else if if you tell
me something off the record and then
bill tells me the same thing on the
record and I report it or he tells me on
background my source is going to think I
burned them anyway so it's really it's
to be avoided really on both sides
because it just doesn't work very well
oh and on anonymous sources I not only
am okay with him I think they're
absolutely essential I think moat a lot
of really great journalism would never
have happened it had not been for
anonymous sources I think they're key
yeah right here I think this I think my
question would be best preface and
saying that you know I come from a
military family and then when my dad was
a station in camp mountain he went to
Iraq in his early two thousand seven
this is when IEDs were still wreaking
havoc the general held a meeting for
military families kind of giving us the
lowdown of what was going on over there
and the only thing was is that before I
went to that meeting I read i think was
just in like yahoo news feed or
something like this i've read about em
raps and I you know that in the article
is said something like you know this
still hasn't been implemented yet it's
you know got contractual problems that
kind of stuff so I talked with the
general basically about that being like
one of these things going to be
implemented and he promptly told me that
you know if he ever finds a person who
leaked this story or who reported in a
bar that this is gonna be a very bad day
for that person so my questions kind of
two part in that like something
something like that should it be out in
the general public knowledge what good
does it do for the general public to be
reading these things when it's not
really fully implemented by the military
yet and also if I was a reporter and I
had this story and I was uncomfortable
with reporting this because of these
certain things how would i go about not
reporting that well so he the general is
upset because the
the program about to implement to send
these mine-resistant armored vehicles to
Iraq wasn't up and ready to go yet yet
it was being reported on by the press
but the problem and this is exactly this
is a story with the press I think did a
fairly good job because the problem was
the Pentagon and particularly under the
rum soul administration was very slow to
acknowledge that maybe these expensive
but much more armored vehicles would be
of use in Iraq they keep kept they were
under the delusion that the war was
winding down that by the time they got
these things built and sent over there
they wouldn't really need them anymore
they be spending a lot of money on
something that wasn't going to make that
much of a difference and it wasn't until
secretary gates got in and sort of lit a
fire under them that they really ramped
up the MRAP protection and this is a
case where the press I think reported
accurately that the military but the
Marines in particular but but the army
as well were just very very slow to put
in place technology that was potentially
going to save the lives of American
troops that's what the rep the press
ought to be doing and if I met that
general in a bar he'd be a very bad day
for him well maybe I not physically but
I would definitely give him a piece of
my mind yeah
yeah well that would be really dumb
logic but you see a lot of that in the
military where they're so insulated
they're also thinking just about their
own narrow little problem and how this
could possibly that they're missing the
big picture that's why we have civilian
control of the military you know the old
expression that the war is too important
to be left to the generals that's why
you have to have a civilian leader come
in and crack the whip over these guys
because they're in this mindset they
planned things so long their budgets for
things if they got to move money for EM
wraps are going to have to take it away
from something else they get so locked
into this thinking you know that's
exactly the kind of flawed military
thinking that results in disaster and
you think well how did these smart
people got to be generals make such dumb
decisions well of course the civilians
could make dumb decisions too but that's
a you know that's just an example they
were just way too slow to recognize the
problem they were too enamored of their
scenario of how they thought this was
going to go out they were sick they
thought the war was ending they were
going to be leaving you know they
thought they were only gonna have 30,000
troops in Iraq you know six months after
well it turned out they were wrong and
they needed to adapt and one of the one
of the keys to good policy is to
recognize when you when things have
changed and to adapt to it and of course
you know once we send more em wraps over
there then the insurgents adapt to that
too so goes back and forth
can you elaborate a little bit more on
the leadership style from Casper
Weinberger up to former Secretary Robert
Gates and how would that affect the
acquiring of information whether that be
confidential information or public
source information and clear touch base
on the China threat to the United States
and their spread in South and Central
America thank you well I wasn't there
for Weinberger but I started with Cheney
and went through went through gates so I
won't be able to come in you know in
terms of the relationship the who's in
charge in the civilians and the flow of
information in the Pentagon I didn't see
a lot of change I mean they all come in
they all complain about leaks they all
claim they're going to crack down they
all scare people at some point there's
24,000 people in the Pentagon somebody's
always talking you know they just can't
stop anything that went when secretary
gates put a policy rotor policy about
tightening up information and stopping
leaks that leaked within you know a half
an hour the policy leaked within a half
an hour you know each of the defense
secretaries had a different personality
probably the least effective one when i
was there was Aspen les aspin you know
among the most effective was William
Perry who was who had this sort of
mathematicians brain and could reduce
things to their essential arguments and
carry the day I think Rumsfeld would
have been seen as a great defense
secretary had the Iraq war gone
differently I think in many respects he
gets a bad rap he was a lot of fun to
cover he did a lot of things very
controversial but he also you know much
like gates took a firm control of the
Pentagon which is what the civilians are
supposed to do gates is interesting
because he's the firing its defense
secretary ever Woolsey was complaining
about nobody you know having a
controversy and nobody getting fired
gates doesn't let a controversy goodbye
without firing somebody
whether they're responsible or not
because it goes it plays very well on
Capitol Hill people love it shows
accountability he's a very gates is a
very smart and interesting guy his CIA
background you know he famously said the
press is not the enemy he made a big
speech about that i used to i would
actually frame that and put it outside
my office to remind people that were not
the enemy although as I would point out
the people actually he was wrong about
that we we are the animal we're not the
enemy of the government were were
frenemies were frenemies I'll leave you
to talk about the China threat you
didn't mention bill Cohen who is a kind
of our poet defense secretary for a
while there we traveled with him on a
number of occasions yeah China is a big
issue it's it's a growing problem
there's a debate right now for for many
years the conventional policy wisdom was
let's not do anything to adjust our
policies to China's military buildup
because we could then create a China
threat it was it they called it the
self-fulfilling prophecy it was done by
a Harvard guy named Joan I who was in
the Pentagon and so really you had a
situation where we couldn't respond to
what they were doing so they would shoot
down a satellite you know which is like
a really bad sign if you're in yeah if
you shoot down sat 23 or so of the US
military satellites you're basically
going to put them out of business I mean
that's a fact that that it's a very
unpleasant fact that the military
doesn't want chinese shot down a
satellite in january of 07 and now
they're building an anti-ship ballistic
missile that's designed to attack
aircraft carriers but there's reluctance
to talk about how to counter that
because then again they want to create
this china threat you know so so but for
many in the military especially at the
you know not the high levels but the
mid-levels they're starting to say look
we got a big problem and if we don't
because it takes so long to develop
weapons systems to counter these things
if we don't start doing something now
we're going to be in big trouble in five
or ten years
you know what's going on in China today
it's you basically have this
nuclear-armed communist dictatorship
that you know about 30 years ago
abandoned the economics of
marxism-leninism but not the politics of
it in fact their system is basically a
soviet-style system i mean it's it's a
dictatorship of the proletariat with a
collective about seven people they have
power ministries they have a strong
military and and they have this
socialist economy that's booming so
they're trying to make themselves a
model for other places in the world
they're moving into Africa buying up
countries buying up resources they're
using a massive amounts of resources so
there's going to be kind of an emerging
global conflict or competition for
resources and I think we're that's
playing out most immediately in the
South China Sea with recent tensions
there you have the Chinese and squaring
off with the Vietnamese over some
disputed islands the Chinese are saying
that this is our the entire sea is our
core interest and there's a lot of oil
and gas resources there which are
Vietnam and the Philippines and other
states are vying for trying to get
access to those so it's a big problem
there's a big debate it hasn't been
resolved just recently the the Pentagon
announced what they call a new concept
they call it the air-sea battle concept
it sounds very obtuse but basically what
it is it's directed against the Chinese
and it's trying to develop better
communications and interoperability
between the Nathan AV scrutiny between
the Navy and the Air Force and so that's
one thing that they're doing under
Rumsfeld they had something called the
hedge strategy which hedged meaning to
bet on both sides and so they were
developed saying look we think China
will develop as a peaceful power but
we're not sure they won't tell us why
they're building anti-satellite weapons
and anti-ship ballistic missiles so we
need to develop capabilities to be ready
in case they want to threaten
our allies in Asia okay how we doing
timewise here we got time for a couple
more questions I think sure Stephen so
no an issue we had like a week or two
ago was when I spoke to an expert that
you were cautious about and so my
question is just dealing with experts
like that we heard from the experts side
of the field that you have to be careful
about who you talk to depending on how
long they've been out of there so how do
you feel about using sources from think
tanks in other fields especially because
there's so many of them with so many
different points of view and possible
different conflicting interests on their
parts as we discussed sure the use of
the Washington expert this is a kind of
journalistic device in a lot of ways to
really try to provide what Jamie called
the context to a story experts at think
tanks can give you the what it all means
quote for your story to kind of put into
context what what the news story is all
about and I think it's it's useful to
kind of understand the political
leanings of of the various think tanks
and Washington's and in my view
everything in Washington is tinged with
politics no matter what they tell you
about something being purely objective
if you look at who their board members
are if you look at who their funding is
if you can find that it will give you a
sense of where they come from in a lot
of cases you know the the idea of a
think tank used to be that this was
where people from the opposite party
would go when they were out of
government and then when their
administration came in then they would
go back into government so they were
kind of like holding tanks for a lot of
officials so I think that's kind of the
tradition there so in the political
perspective I think you'd have to say
the Brookings Institution kind of is on
the the liberal the liberal side there
are some newer
Democratic oriented Center for American
Progress and those that kind of are on
the left of the political spectrum CSIS
Center for Strategic international
studies used to be directly part of
Georgetown its separate they used to be
somewhat to write a center they now may
be somewhat a little bit left but but
fairly Center the American Enterprise
Institute is considered more
neoconservative the Heritage Foundation
across the street they're more of a
traditionalist more economic oriented
conservativism so it's useful to try and
understand that I think you can if you
were to just kind of search for some of
these think tanks and some of these
people you could find out what they may
have said about other issues and that
will give you a sense of where they're
coming from yeah I would just say about
going to experts for your stories it's
the last place you should go I know I
mean you shouldn't go there I just mean
you should be the last place in other
words when you see sometimes you see
reporters who let's say they're supposed
to do a story about em reps to Iraq I
don't know anything about em raps to
Iraq so the first thing they do is they
call up the you know some think tank the
Institute for study of em reps or
something and they calls them because
they don't think I think they interview
the expert he tells them what the story
is and then they sort of pursue that
story it's that's the backwards way to
do it you know I didn't use a lot of
experts in my reporting because I tended
to just focus on what the facts were you
know here's what the need for em raps
was here's what the army says here's
what some of you but you know eventually
get to a point where you you could have
a line on your story that essentially
says critics say this is bad but
supporters say it's not so bad and
sometimes you need somebody to say that
so you know that you made so after
you've done the reporting and you kind
of know what the tus what the sides are
you might want to find someone who can
articulate that so you don't so you
don't have to just say you know critics
say the Obama administration is wrong on
his Israeli policy but other other
supporters say he's doing just the right
thing so you take you find someone who's
going to put those into where somebody's
smart who knows the issue and but you by
the time you go to them you already know
sort of like what you
part of the story you need to sort of
fill out and that's how I tended to use
the experts I would develop people who I
thought were smart and pretty much new
things and everyone saw they'd surprise
me and have an opinion that was
significantly different than what I
thought but I would use them to just
sort of to sort of buttress the
reporting I already done I just think
the mistake that too many people make is
they just call it to the lazy way to
report you don't anything about missile
defense so you call the you know
somebody who studies missile defense and
whatever they tell you that's kind of
what your story how your story goes that
just gets the backwards way to do it you
touched upon a little bit about doing
everything yourself and I just wondered
what your guys thoughts were upon like
mobile reporting and just basically
getting things out on like laptops and
on cell phones make that like having the
ability to get information out right
away if you if you really need to spread
that out yeah well you know life is full
of little trade-offs and also the world
is changing and you can't you know you
can't the Mon you know it's like yeah I
always worried about just sitting around
the newsroom something like I was some
dinosaurs me like you know in my day why
you used to go out and cover the news
not like you whippersnappers today
because I think that's what we sound
like sometimes we start talking about
you know how we did things in the old
days it's life and you have to deal with
it it is harder to do certain kinds of
stories you know it's it's great for
certain things like you know if a
tornado hits in wipes out Joplin
Missouri the mobile reporting can be
much faster and give you a much faster
idea if it's a complex story like wolves
he was talking about the you know the
middle ground of people who are
nonviolent extra story then this kind of
rushed reporting doesn't serve very well
but you know the the reality is we get a
mix of all of that and there hopefully
they'll still be some of these
organizations who are taking the time to
do complicated stories in a way that
really explains them a really good
example of that by the way was the often
security national security issue but the
recent statement from the world health
organization that that cell phones
may cause cancer in the same sense that
you may win the lottery it could happen
you know most of the initial reporting
on that was really shallow didn't do
anything to help you understand the
science behind it but eventually some
people caught up Time magazine did a
great piece and their current issue on
cancer really sort of explaining what
the science is and what that what that
was all about but you don't see a lot of
that on a complicated story like that
until usually some time has passed okay
you've got time for one more question
what's okay you are I'm curious how I
have the chance of summer to do some
covering of just foreign affairs
intelligence security issues and I think
a lot of times it's just kind of jumping
into the field for the first time here I
feel like I'm kind of picking up the
leftovers of you know what people are
actually in the field are actually
covering and I'm just trying to cut pick
through news stories and you know a lot
of us I think our interns and we're
young and we haven't had a chance to
develop sources with Pentagon officials
and things like that so what's your
advice for someone who's young just
trying to kind of get their nose in the
air at the very start and find something
that's actually unique has a unique
point of view and you know just not
something that's being reported over and
over already well one event you have is
that you are young and you do have a
unique point of view I mean I think all
of us have reporters have had this
experience of going into an area where
everybody else has been covering it for
four years and your brand new and
suddenly you see something that hasn't
struck any of the people there because
it's just they just see it all the time
so part of its just keeping your eyes
open just thinking about things in
different ways realizing that you may
have it you may bring different things
to it you know you do run the risk of
and this is the other thing you see is
it every time a new reporter comes on
the beat somebody discovers a story that
everybody else has reported you know and
reports it as if it's brand new i just
saw i think it was i think it was Diane
Sawyer on ABC did a story about the
playing the Doomsday plane did you see
this story well you know I think it
bill mentioned that we flew on we fly on
these planes that don't that refuel in
the air one the planes we fly is this
it's the e4 be it used to be the
doomsday plan it's not really a doomsday
plane anymore but it's a flying command
center and the in the defense secretary
likes to fly it because it too full you
know it's a 747 with no windows and a
big hump on the top where they have
communications equipment it's a very
cool plane and so the first time you go
on it probably like the first time you
walk up the driveway of the White House
your kind of impressed but every once in
while the new reporter comes on the
plane they've never seen it before and
it ends up with the story about the
plane and it's so it's kind of a joke
after a while and sure enough Diane
Sawyer went to interview gates flew on
the plane next you know was a feature on
ABC about the Doomsday plane and it's
always slightly hyped it always makes
sound like this plane is you know ready
to take to the skies in the event of a
nuclear war and in fact that mission is
kind of gone away technically it's all
true but it's a you know they love
telling the story it sort of feeds into
the legend and so you know you you are
so sort of susceptible to that is the
new kid on the block but also you can
sometimes just have a fresh perspective
and see thing and connect dots in a way
that people haven't by just keeping your
mind up and the one piece of advice that
I would give you and I think this is
true whether you're reporting a story or
whether you're a news organization
trying to come up in the identity is
don't pay much attention to what
everybody else is doing just think for
yourself now you know the temptation is
well these guys have been you know these
Network reporter they've been doing this
for years I need to sort of see what
they're doing I can learn from them well
that's true to an extent but you almost
always do better if like bill was
talking about you go to something and
you're trying to figure out what the
news is well if you go to the AP wire
and see well let's see what ap led with
oh okay I'm going to go with their story
you're much better off just never
reading the wires never looking at what
your competition does maybe after you've
done your story you might take a look
and just thinking for yourself and you
develop that ability to to just think
for yourself and yeah you're going to
miss a few things and sometimes but
ninety percent of the time you will have
better original take on something by
just figuring it out yourself then
spending too much time looking over your
shoulder at everybody
yeah quickly from I go for those stories
where there's some type of conflict or
even anticipated conflict I think those
will produce good news stories and look
for things that haven't been reported
you know in order to know what hasn't
been reported you have to find out
what's been reported so you have to know
the subject areas that you're you're
working in especially and then try to
find something that hasn't been reported
or something that's new or something
that's a new development and again you
know ask people ask who knows is what's
going on with this what's going to
happen a lot of times congressional
testimony and congressional reports a
very good source material you can mine
them members of Congress will talk about
something that has you know only been
mentioned briefly they'll they'll talk
about classified things that are in an
unclassified way and that will be
reflective of stuff that can produce
news stories okay I think you had one
question in the in the back there will
give you the last question I was just
wondering what your thoughts were on the
claim that certain news agencies are
becoming more ideological I was
wondering if you thought there were any
pressure on reporters to report certain
stories that kind of fit into certain
ideologies I don't see that I mean you
know my own views are that like I say in
Washington everything is tinged with
politics you know I do escribe that
there's a certain mainstream media bias
you know I mean like I said I had a
run-in with a bomb administration
official who basically accused my
newspaper of being a you know a biased
news organization but you know it's very
relative in political terms most
newspapers they just try to shoot down
the middle but then they cover some
stories that no one else will cover I
think gays in the military is one of
them you know I mean that's that's an
area that's a very hotly contested issue
you know the conventional wisdom is that
you know they should lift the ban a lot
of people in the military don't think
it's a good idea
but yeah that's probably as much as I
have on that yeah I'd suggested in the
time that I was at CNN for instance no
one ever never felt any pressure to
report a particular story report in a
particular way but television is about
ratings is about selling commercials and
ratings and as as it got more
competitive as CNN more competitors and
show producers were empowered to try to
win the ratings of their time slot it
became harder and harder to get certain
kinds of stories on the air so for
instance if I called CNN as I did one
time and proposed I wanted to do a story
about France was taking a larger role in
NATO's military structure after having
been away from it from him a long time I
thought it was an important significant
change in the NATO alliance no show
producer at CNN was interested in
running that story they didn't see that
as something that Americans would be all
that interested in and so there was a
time when I first worked at CNN where I
could just do that story and it would
just run by the time I left CNN partly
because of the increased competition
wasn't competing with fox or MSNBC or
anybody else so there was there was a
sort of a self-reinforcing process for
certain kinds of stories again stories
that had a villain in them or you know
showed waste fraud and abuse or some
provoked outrage it was much easier to
get those on the on the air and so in
that case I there's there was sort of a
process in which the types of stories
you could you kind of knew which stories
you could do and get on the air in which
ones were going to be a much harder sell
I mean obviously if you really thought
something was tremendously important but
nobody was gaining on you could sort of
appeal and maybe get you know stories on
now and then that maybe weren't going to
be you know big ratings boosters but
that was just sort of a you know it just
it was sort of a limited process ok
thank you all very much really